ROGER MARTINEZ:
Today, we're talking
about VMware Engine, Apache
Cassandra, and Google Cloud
Next.
I'm Roger Martinez.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
For the past year, we've been
working to support customers
with VMware workloads.
And now, we're happy to announce
that the effort has grown
into a fully managed service.
Google Cloud VMware Engine
offers end-to-end support
to migrate and run your VMware
environments on Google Cloud
Platform.
Check out the blog
to learn more.
Apache Cassandra is an
open source database
built on a scale-out
architecture
to support applications with
a massive amount of data.
To make it easier for customers
to deploy, manage, and scale
their Cassandra workloads, we're
introducing DataStax Astra,
with Cassandra as a service.
Try it today and create
a Cassandra cluster
on Google Cloud in
minutes without worrying
about operational overhead.
Google Cloud is dedicated
to helping customers
maximize their business
value without maximizing
their budget.
We offer many tools
to help developers
stay on top of their costs.
But there are always
techniques and tips
that could help you
optimize your costs.
This blog post covers
several high-level principles
that organizations can follow
to ensure that they're getting
the most out of their cloud.
We've spent the last
few months working
to evolve Next 2020 into a
worthwhile digital experience.
And now, we're pretty
proud of what we've built.
Starting on July 14, join us
for a nine-week digital event.
Next OnAir will offer
fresh content each week,
with over 200
sessions in total, all
built around providing
compelling content,
connecting you with experts,
and growing your skills.
If you want to read more
about the announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment, or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.